l'amendement de Jean-Paul matthi il va
il est quand même pas révolutionnaire il
dit de manière provisoire on a besoin
d'argent et là il y en a et il y en a
peut-être chez des gens qui ont déjà
largement de quoi et qui se payent en
dividende qui sont même pas la société
moi je je je vous incite à réfléchir au
messages qu'on envoie on peut demander
des efforts aux gens mais à ce moment-là
il faut le demander à tout le monde et
là notamment on touche pas des gens qui
euh j'allais dire où la à quelqu
augmentation qui va leur être fait bah
déstabiliser leur fortune quoi je trouve
que c'est un amendement euh qui a le
mérite d'aller toucher des revenus qui
ne sont pas redistribués de manière
directe dans l'économie et qui surtout
là encore alors peut-être que les gens
ici trouvent que c'est normal mais
enrichissent j'allais dire de
manière évidemment trop importante
certains de nos concitoyens au détriment
j'allais dire l'effort national que
chacun doit faire nous sommes dans une
période où l'effort national doit être
fait tout le monde le dit pour tout le
monde il serait normal que tous ceux qui
bénéficient très largement de ce qui a
permis de faire en sorte que le capital
soit moins imposé ces dernières années
contribue à cet effort exceptionnel les
provocation pardon se multiplie quand on
voit que Total qui doit tout à la France
et absolument tout aux Français se
permet de tenir à l'étranger une
assemblée générale où il annonce la
hausse de son dividende alors que les
consommateurs les automobilistes
français souffrent et enrichissent à
leur insu les profits c'est
particulièrement indécent donc on se
rend bien compte que contrairement à ce
que pensait la macronie ce genre de
multinationale n'écoute que ses intérêts
et le marché qu'il faut leur rappeler à
ce qu'il doivent à la patrie ce que nous
essayons de faire ce que la majorité
essaie de faire depuis maintenant 6 ans
c'est justement d'apporter de la
stabilité fiscale le mérite de cette
flat taxe et qu plus elle est je peux
comprendre qu'on a qu'elle soit contesté
mais c'est qu'elle apporte de la
stabilité dans le temps de la lisibilité
et j' envie dire ça paye ça paye parce
que les investissements en France ont
augmenté ça paye parce que
l'attractivité de notre pays a augmenté
30 % franchement c'est c'est pas le
paradis fiscal 30 % c'est la moyenne
c'est même au-dessus de la moyenne
européenne